l'irak un autre pays miné par la
présence du groupe armé état islamique
et pour le combattre le gouvernement
s'appuie sur plusieurs milices armées
mais ces milices pourrait aussi
amplifier le chaos dans le pays
elles sont pour la plupart de confession
chiite et agissent bien souvent dans des
zones sunnites
c'était le cas à titre est une ville
importante que les milices ont réussi à
reprendre au groupe etat islamique
marie-eve bédard et sylvain castonguay
se sont rendus à tikrit tu
il nous raconte comment les combattants
du milices chiites ont commis des actes
qui pourraient être des crimes de guerre
depuis qu'elle a été reprise par les
forces gouvernementales
la ville de tikrit tu as désert post
apocalyptique
partout le regard se pose destruction et
désolation amira est une des rares à
être revenue vivre dans ce quartier du
nord de la ville depuis mai dernier
la veuve s'étaient accrochés pendant un
bon moment sa maison alors que ses
voisins fuyaient la ville où se joignent
au groupe armé islamique le nomme
ouhlala ah ok nous ne dormions pas nous
ne mangions pas une vivions dans la peur
il ne laissait personne bouger ou faire
quoi que ce soit tous les jours il
attaqué des maisons fouillées pour
trouver les armes des anciens policiers
il joue avec nous comme il le voulait la
terreur elle la ressentait surtout pour
ses enfants des lois les pêcheurs
nous avons un fils dans la police ils
nous demandaient pourquoi est ce que ton
fils est un traître des budgets amira et
ses enfants fini par partir après que
son fils policier est été arrêté et
torturé par le lit quand ils sont
revenus une fois tikrit libérés ils ont
retrouvé leur maison incendiée en fait
une bonne partie du quartier a été brûlé
les voisins ont aussi voulu nous montrer
les ruines calcinées de la maison mais
tous ont refusé d'être filmé ou
d'expliquer ce qui s'était passé
le petit marché la maison du docteur
jamal al hadith y ont aussi été
anéanties par les flammes et lui fait
exception ils disent avoir un
responsable des centaines de maisons et
commerces et calcinée adèle la
démolition c'est le i qui en est
responsable mais les incendies ce ne
sont pas sûrs après la libération de
tikrit quand l'armée et les milices qui
l'appuient sont entrés dans la ville
il ya eu des incendies de la destruction
et du vol human rights watch a publié un
rapport sur les abus des milices après
la reprise de ti creed qui corrobore
cette affirmation et qui va même plus
loin
après avoir analysé des images
satellites les vidéos de survol menés
par les avions de la coalition et
conduit des dizaines d'entrevues avec
des témoins l'organisme conclut que les
milices pro gouvernementales sont
responsables d'une destruction
systématique à grande échelle et d'
arrestations extrajudiciaires en
violation du droit humanitaire et du
droit de la guerre de possibles crimes
de guerre commis par vengeance croit le
docteur allah dit i il voulait se venger
du massacre de spyker il croyait que
tous les propriétaires de ces commerces
y avaient participé
mais dans les faits nous n'avons rien à
voir avec cette affaire-là
cette affaire dont il parle c'est sans
doute l'une des plus macabres de
l'histoire récente de l'irak en juin
2014 et milliers de recrues de l'armée
irakienne ont été faits prisonniers par
lui alors qu'il tentait de fuir le camp
spyker et chiites ont été prises à part
il mener à leur mort sur le site
d'anciens palais de saddam hussein le yi
affirme avoir exécuté 1700 soldats ce
jour là au moins 600 cadavres ont été
exhumés depuis la reprise de tikrit le
lieu de naissance de saddam hussein a
donné une victoire symbolique importante
aux forces irakiennes aux milices
populaires shit et à la coalition mais
c'était en avril dernier et encore
aujourd'hui creed demeure la seule ville
importante qui était passé au maître lui
dont le gouvernement irakien à retrouver
le contrôle après tu écris tu les forces
qui combattent le i devait pousser vers
mossoul plus au nord mais depuis
quelques mois plus personne ne parle de
libérer la deuxième ville d'irak
une partie du problème croît ce
politicien cynique c'est que combat
s'appuient beaucoup trop sur les milices
chiites marge de la lutte contre lui
ahmed al moutlak redoutent le retour des
violences confessionnelles qui ont
marqué les années de l'occupation
américaine
mais aujourd'hui les états unis ont
laissé toute la place à une autre
puissance selon lui l'iran c'est
inquiétant pour les irakiens
si ces milices recevaient leurs ordres
de l'irak ce serait une chose mais elles
reçoivent leurs ordres de l'extérieur
c'est très dangereux
obama en forme d'araignée d'hôtel shérif
un danger qui pourrait mettre le feu à
la poudrière que représente la gronde
populaire qui se manifeste désormais
ouvertement un ras-le-bol qui exige
entre autres que le premier ministre al
abadi casse le moule de la politique
basée sur les lignes de fracture
confessionnelle
cette volonté du peuple une armée morale
puissance nationale du premier ministre
n'est peut-être pas suffisante pour
contrer les armes bien réelles de toutes
ces milices